[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to this episode we're covering the
2019 reboot of Hellboy whilst the film
is a more faithful adaptation for fans
of the franchise the film unfortunately
fails in several ways and feels like a
clumsy depiction of the right hand of
doom that will leave audience members
leaving with a clenched fist throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
Hell boys post-credit scenes and what
they tease for the future for if this
movie makes more than $10,000 at the box
office this is full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't seen the movie yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I hope you enjoy the video now
sit back relax and let's get into my
ending exclaimed-- breakdown of Hellboy
2019 the film follows Hellboy as he
tries to take down the Blood Queen and
stop her from destroying the world the
Queen was killed by King Arthur who cut
her into pieces and did the old spread
her body parts to opposite ends of the
earth stick that film's love to do these
days it's your average game of collect
the body parts that requires the
villains to reassemble the Queen in
order to put Humpty Dumpty back together
again and bring her back to life he
basically wants to end the world and
bring hell to the surface juxtaposing
this Hellboy is actually suspected of
being the one that will bring forth the
apocalypse the Queen uses this ambiguity
to trick Hellboy and the majority of the
movies tension comes from wondering
whether he will actually be the one that
ends the world or not we get an amazing
scene that sort of plays this out and
worlds the rest of the movie is about as
entertaining as watching you granddad
say pull my finger before he fart in
your face his adds to ality to the
character in order to track down the
Queen Hellboy enlists the help of Baba
Yaga who it's hinted at has crossed
paths with Hellboy in the past and after
their battle was banished to another
dimension
Yaga helps Emmet though she states that
in return for the favor she wants one of
his
whilst this has never resolved directly
in the movie the scene is brought up
again after the credits in a segment
that sees Baba Yaga offering a deal to
an unknown person Yaga wants this
mysterious figure to kill Hellboy and to
bring one of his eyes in exchange now
let's just say hypothetically that this
movie makes more than Avengers endgame
and a sequel is greenlit what exactly
can we expect to see in it well in the
comics Baba Yaga's I was originally shut
out by Hellboy after he hunted her down
whilst investigating a string of
children's disappearances our boy
managed to defeat her and send her into
a pocket dimension that resembled Russia
long before civilization was ever
created there we would likely have this
backstory fully fleshed out in a sequel
as here it's kind of skipped over
there's no indicator of who this mystery
man could be but it could potentially be
Rasputin as the two have worked together
in the comics on several occasions
whilst Rasputin has already appeared in
the original Hellboy film adaptation it
makes sense for his presence to be
brought back once more as he's able to
travel through dimensions and is also
one of the character's greatest foes
he's also in that amazing boney M song
which accompli cuz this video will get
flagged but just look at those dance
moves appreciate that yeah you don't see
that anymore anyway the film also
heavily teases Abe Sapien and it's
ending and honestly this was the
character out of the franchise that I
was hoping to see the most the
amphibious man's just coming back off
his Oscar win in the shape of water and
he of course was a big talking point in
the original films so it makes sense to
bring him back in the comics Abe can
breathe underwater and swim faster than
Aquaman similar to Rasputin Abe is also
thought to be immortal so it makes sense
to bring these two characters back for
the thumbs down the line he's one of
hell boys most trusted allies and would
make for a great character going forward
if they manage to improve the CGI in
these movies and finally the other post
credits scene shows Hellboy in a
graveyard mourning the loss of his
father how boy is pretty drunk probably
because he's read the reviews for this
film which is when he's approached by
lobster Johnson lobster Johnson was
actually my nickname in school cuz all
the girls said I had a red
never mind anyway lobster states that he
wants to get Hellboy back in the
fighting which is when the rest of the
credits start to roll so what exactly
does this signify well in the comics
lobster is a vigilante detective that's
pretty much a cross between Batman and
the Punisher he's went through numerous
reincarnations sometimes being dead and
resurrected and other times being
someone who's just done the mantle the
character was actually the star of
several foreign films from the 30s to
50s though not many of the original
prints survived hopefully this film gets
lost to air I shouldn't shouldn't say
that really people have put a lot of
work into this and for me it just ripped
it apart like that it's not nice anyway
the two will need to team up if they're
to take on what's to come and Johnson
could become the dark knight of the
universe to hell Boys Man of Steel and
now on to my review whilst I'm normally
someone who tends to disagree with the
big outlets such as IGN I actually found
myself agreeing with them on this one
Hellboy is konzi poorly paced and tries
to fit far too much into its short run
time whilst BVS did this and suffered to
it at least had longer to juggle the
story's ala boy on the other hand just
feels like wants to drop as many Easter
eggs as possible that only hardcore fans
will understand and due to this and
alienate the majority of its audience
there's just it's hard to describe it if
you haven't seen it really I think if
this was a TV show that had more time to
develop its plot points or it was a
longer movie that it could probably pull
this off however things whizzed by and
as a feeling of real detachment
throughout David Harbor just doesn't
possess the charisma that Ron Perelman
had and this makes the character really
hard to engage with Milla Jovovich is it
Miller Djokovic
anymore anyway Miller is trying to
darkness and she's probably the best
part of the movie and she could have
really shown with better material
overall though the film is very muddled
and I'm gonna take a cue from IGN on
this one and say four out of ten too
much hell not enough boy and of course
love to hear your thoughts on the film
and if you disagree with me make sure
you leave your review in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of this week's big
Netflix release the silence which would
be linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]